this still is the crazy time of the year
where games are being played
but teams are looking for coaches no one
has been hired yet
all quiet in jacksonville i'm told that
they're still
working toward the possibility of urban
meyer becoming the coach you don't hear
any other names coming up they
interviewed
arthur smith on sunday night they
checked that box no other discussions of
other interviews
monday or tuesday they're focused on
urban meyer and we'll see where that
goes and we'll see
what else is happening good afternoon
shireen how's everything
i'm just trying to stay in my lane today
mike just stay in your lane
staying in the lane is always the way to
go sometimes the lane gets a little
wider with everything that's going on
but yes we we stay
in our lane and we get you through an
afternoon
of nfl developments this one and we're
going to start in houston
is both surprising
and not surprising because the houston
texans
who did not interview chief's offensive
coordinator eric b enemy
last week during kansas city's buy
and the enemy the guy reportedly
suggested to ownership by quarterback
deshaun watson at the behest of chiefs
quarterback
patrick uh chiefs quarterback patrick
mahomes the enemy now is going to be
interviewed
by the houston texans the problem is
they can't interview the enemy until the
chiefs are done playing
so are these chiefs going are the t
are the texans going to actually wait
until after the super bowl potentially
simply to talk to eric the enemy
regardless of whether or not they
actually hire him
are you going to put your entire process
on hold
until after the super bowl just to
placate
the guy that you have made angry
and potentially pushed to the point
where he wants out of town
because you didn't interview him last
week shireen i can't believe it i can't
believe it that ship has sailed
that that is over that is done i'm
stunned by this development but i'm not
because it fits right within the messed
up way the texans are doing things right
now
yeah no question about it mike and
here's the weird thing too
like eric the enemy as i understand the
rule you could correct me if i'm wrong
here
but i think teams that have already
talked to him virtually can
meet with him assuming the chiefs go to
the super bowl
teams that have already virtually met
with him if it's a second interview
could talk to him during that off week
between the championship game and the
super bowl but the texans would be
unable to do that
because the window has closed on virtual
interviews so
am i correcting this eric the enemy
actually could be hired by somebody
before the texans even get a chance to
talk to him
well he can definitely be interviewed a
second time by the teams that have
already interviewed him once and that's
five of the other teams looking for
coaches
and yeah he he could be the focal point
he could be
unofficially hired we know that under
the rules right and the rules need to
change
you can't hire the guy until the
season's over and and i'm going to write
something at some point on pft
advocating
and this is something peter king has
argued in the past and i think the time
has come for it
everything gets delayed until after
the super bowl has happened because it
really does create a distraction
for the teams that are still left in the
playoffs you've got
candidates who are getting ready for
interviews which are
necessarily far more important to them
and their families than the next
playoff game of their teams as as one
person explained it to me recently
when the assistant coach who's a
candidate for a head coaching job comes
home from work
on the tuesday night before a playoff
game
that person's spouse doesn't say how's
the game planning going for the playoff
game
that person's spouse says have you heard
anything about this new job you may be
getting that becomes the focal point
necessarily so
that but until that happens yeah these
are the rules and the texans blew their
chance
to talk to the enemy last week and to be
able to talk to him in the dead week
between the conference championship
games in the super bowl if it lasts that
long
i mean right now the texans just need to
hope that the browns beat the chiefs or
the following week the ravens bills
winner beat the chiefs and
and then they get a chance to talk to
the enemy otherwise
they they may be prevented from hiring a
coach until we get into early february
unless all of a sudden they've decided
to hire the enemy
which would make their decision from
last week even more ludicrous it would
reflect that they have decided to do
everything they can
to keep desean watson but how could you
how could you decide to hire eric b
enemy when he wasn't even one of your
potential interviewees a week ago and
you haven't even interviewed him and now
you're just gonna wait until after the
super bowl harm
none of it makes any sense and i
understand that they may be trying
to rebuild the relationship with deshaun
watson
and maybe maybe this is sharing because
yesterday when we were hearing these
other names
jim caldwell leslie frazier you know
guys who would come in and be very
even-keeled and calm the exact opposite
of bill o'brien and so many coaches look
for the guy who's the exact opposite of
the guy they had
from a personality standpoint caldwell
fraser
calm collected not f-bombs not yelling
not screaming
and and you know deshawn watson's kind
of a quiet guy they
maybe they thought that that would work
and i tried to poke around yesterday and
see if that would work and i couldn't
get anywhere
maybe they tried to poke around and see
if it would work too and they didn't get
anywhere so they decided well
half measure isn't going to work we just
better go ahead and bite the bullet
and interview the enemy even if it means
waiting until after the super bowl
it it really is bizarre
but it does show that they have realized
how badly they screwed up the
relationship
with deshaun watson and they've decided
that it's a priority to try to fix it
whether they can fix it or not we'll see
hey mike i'm wondering did they do this
on purpose in other words did they wait
until this week to request an
interview permission to interview eric
the enemy so that
they can go back and tell desean hoping
that he gets hired by someone else in
the meantime
or he turns down that request to say hey
we we requested him he turned it down or
he was hired by somebody else but we put
in the request we wanted to talk to eric
the enemy
i do wonder if this is part of their
ploy here
to to kind of make desean happy but you
anybody can read through this if that's
what ends up happening or if the texans
hire another head coach
it absolutely is to just say to deshaun
watson
okay we'll request an interview with him
and we're going to hire somebody else
anyway so
it's the whole thing is just weird and
it just plays into exactly what this
organization
is and has been and will continue to be
apparently as they move forward which as
i've said multiple times
the worst run organization in the nfl
over the last year or so that they've
managed to just
mortgage their future and do everything
possibly wrong that they could do
i don't know that i give them enough
credit to have come up with a plan like
that even though it's a stupid plan
isn't that the ultimate insult we don't
think you're smart enough
to come up with a ridiculously dumb plan
that's how bad it is right now in
houston and that's what nick casario is
trying
to address as the new gm of the team
andre johnson the first great superstar
of the houston texans
he chimed in with some strong support
for deshaun watson and his apparent
desire to dig in
until he gets traded and uh here's what
johnson had to say if i'm desean watson
i will stand my ground the texas
organization is known for wasting
players careers since jack easterby has
walked into the building nothing good
has happened
in slash for the organization and for
some reason
someone can't seem to see what's going
on pathetic
three exclamation points that someone is
cal mcnair the owner of the team
and let me tell you if i'm jack eastwood
right now i'm getting nervous all over
again
because it wasn't that long ago that
easter b's influence had diminished to
almost nothing it wasn't that long ago
that the gm candidates were suggesting
that moving forward
get rid of jack easterby and then jack
easterby goes to cal mcnair's house
and abracadabra nick casario comes from
off the board to be the gm
and easter bee is safe i think this
whole this whole push to get rid of jack
easterby
is back it's real and he's going to have
to go back to cal mcnear's house and try
to
try to try some other magic spell
whatever it is that he's using to keep
cal mcnair
in his corner it's going to be tested
like never before because the fact that
they're looking at these
candidates unless this is a completely
transparent effort
to play kate desean watson it it's
moving toward
cal mcnair finally snapping out of it
and we'll see if that ultimately happens
we'll see if he listens to andre johnson
or anyone else who's saying that this
organization
right now is in horrible shape and the
influence of jackie's to be and this is
what you get look there's nothing
personal
this is what you get when you give the
keys to an nfl franchise
to someone who isn't qualified who
doesn't have the credentials
who doesn't have the experience and who
has just been trying to climb and climb
and climb and gain
power he's gotten power and he has no
idea
how to properly use it to lead to a
properly and
successfully functioning football team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports